because chances are if one of us we're
gonna have to do that Johnny's there
wouldn't have an episode yeah welcome to
punch drunk sports you know who we are
you know what we're here to do we are
winners
this is puncturing sports where winners
win Wow we got a packed house we got
maybe our pians celebrities I mean you
name it it's big it's big we have this
is a show full of mommies about mommies
yeah congratulations to the fight and
Annie it was now the fight mommy fight
mom and 22 Sunday an evening just went
into labor as predicted during a UFC
fight fight night makes sense i turns
that saturday she naturally with what
what else would the fight nany do go
into labor during a UFC event and so she
had a beautiful baby girl
max Danis yep yeah max so did you little
max do we see her again on the show I
was gonna say and by the way let's
introduce our guest we're gonna take
Fletcher as always and my beautiful
mother yeah beautiful mom is here really
is my mom so Haller's be kind should we
and you can chime in as never mother
your disclaimer I did it really is my
mom and we're not doing a bit somebody
we hired you well you know cool it's not
Jeff Dan it's doing an impression of my
mother um
but should we because look she had a
baby she went into labor Saturday yes
Sunday had the baby yeah and your mom so
you know now to chime in
should we kick her off the show for not
being here today Oh baby two days two
days ago I let's say we take it to a
vote let's start with Aaron I know he
hates children Aaron should the fight
and he be kicked off the show because
she's lazy I have serious questions
about her commitment okay so I'm gonna
go that's a yes
okay that's one vote for get rid of her
John Johnny Johnny Johnny says keeper
why okay they'll give her another chance
he's Johnny saying Johnny you know if
she goes you come to the big big table
nobody know but you don't have to sit
the kids table anymore
well you're not officially on the show
you are a part of the regular regular or
bonsoir show he's a sponsor of the show
he's a regular you've got a lot of
tattoos so well to come back should we
fire her yeah I get if she had the baby
this morning it's a you know I might not
be able to make she makes tens of
dollars off the show every year why
isn't she here tens tens you know how to
legally and I think that right now while
you still have some rights in this
matriarchy that's over running us that
you should probably stand up for
yourself and he'd be a hero for doing so
yeah yeah so you're saying she should
say or go she's got to go wow so that's
one thin ice and if she's already can't
be here today what you can write that
baby needs something in a little bit or
something and then what you're gonna
have around there over there you have a
baby you can't afford a rattle I thought
these tens of dollars tens of dollars to
the baby like the [ __ ] oh wow no we got
three got it goes okay wow that's a lot
of prime going to I'm gonna say the
reason I want to keep her mm-hmm because
eventually Jeff dannis is going to leave
her and she will be very desperate okay
and we will be able to sex trafficker so
I'm gonna keep her as a weirdo weird
reason to keep her I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say keeper okay she's because I
think she brings more to this table than
Johnny I think there's gonna be a lot of
fighting when Johnny gets here she's a
little bit of the eye candy doesn't make
her innocent she she needs a good
talking-to as a mother
definitely needs a good talk to you so
mom you're the deciding vote as a mother
how long a Romy Cachola how long she
keep mom eat it's like when you get
those mom funbags how long do they stay
couple months so she's got at least a
trial period how long are we into the
show oh four minutes into the show and
Sam's already making it creepy with my
mom I want to give it he i I thought it
would over 100 creepy I thought it would
be one way that you guys
hey Fletcher from the back yeah you get
a vote well as a liberal I think she
should get a year off Wow we got vote
for paid leave so we just got a hander
tens of dollars who do we see Ernie here
well we'll give it we'll give him one
more chance but congratulations
congratulations man don't drag up your
tens of dollars probably yeah probably
using it to buy Xbox games against one
spike you know they can't afford an Xbox
maybe some Atari in a rattle you can put
a rattle on layaway with what we pay him
yeah that's a free rattle in six months
yeah that's ridiculous
she's disrespectful I can go visit it
and you know I think the fight nanny
should have a show called the fight
nanny yeah or fight mommy I would she
taught whatever people want to hear what
mmm a motherhood I mean there's probably
not okay
mmm a mother's mix martial arts now
we're talkin if you do how pregnant
ladies in the Octagon yeah and they all
get shit-faced and didn't just talk
about fighters like they're there no I
was saying mothers mmm a-ok mothers
mixed martial arts and it's pregnant
women in octagon fighting we could start
our own league I know it's nice I like
about that mm-hmm
second generation of that very sport the
evolution rights the children they fight
have been beaten up in the womb already
brain damage coming out of the gate and
then they fight eight months later yeah
and now might be a little soon the
playground get him on steroids before we
throw that's why we work back in the
playground in pound we call fight nanny
and ask her where the [ __ ] she is right
now and why she's in here I just call
her ass the ball with us this is a big
day for women's basketball call her
hospital room yeah call the hospital
call the hospital and demand says no
Phil there you know we're watching her
right now
dad you'd have to have such good
insurance to be three days after they
kick you out that day like take your
baby I think she gets no I think they
she told me today she's really my mom
shot it I had money I think she's
squatting at the hospital when my mom
had me she shot me out grabbed me and
carried me out like a backpack my mom
was on he says out of the cave in our
mean
over her back and then set him at the
foot of the mountain and when he
survived the next day when he came back
and said you know what you get to live
you're wrong one I mean he's a lot like
Spartans okay we kill off our week we
only keep the strong and Candice said
she gets back Wednesday now my mom you
gave birth to me true or false you were
on a podcast 45 minutes later you know
the water Cronkite interview whatever
was a radio show you went right back to
your radio she goes on blank ms
public-access giving birth Jason's first
TV right it was birth I came out zingers
yeah I like it stinks up in this [ __ ]
geez how long you known your mom uh what
14 years 15 years where we can we met at
a bar fight
[Music]
Jason where you gonna be
why don't you do yours first and then
I'll do mine and then we'll see what
eights got going on I'm sure you're
gonna die in a movie soon hey do you
have any uh date
are you getting any like appearances
where people can learn like a racism and
stuff like that obviously coffees got a
lot going on yeah we just find us at
caveman coffee we got 10% off punch
drunk listeners right now use a KO punch
listen dude I'm gonna tell you something
dummy I was gonna tell on tinfoil hat
but because you're here I want to tell
you I I sent those black people into
Starbucks to get arrested and give
Starbucks a [ __ ] bad name to help out
caveman cough what if a two black guys
walked into caveman coffee waiting for
their white friend
what would you how would you handle that
you're welcome to loiter all day long
Oh Lloyd they weren't even loitering
there you really know how to make up for
that [ __ ] 300 years of oppression I
let them hang out in your coffee shop
Thanks you should open up a caveman
coffee shop right next to that Starbucks
yeah and for the big sinuses black
people welcome if you uh did you watch
the best movie ever Black Panther it was
the best movie did you see hey dude can
you do I can use the lighter first time
that I watched a movie as maybe black
people watch movies all the time yeah
which is I don't see any people that
look at me that looked like me until the
bad guys are introduced and then there's
like three of them and there's no and
it's like and I thought [ __ ] this is a
weird thing like you just don't know
what you don't know but is there really
one of the only things in it and you
never seen a mainstream movie like that
before where there the voice list where
you really saw how voiceless people are
on it's a trip man and then the way that
that changes when I'm a little kid i
watch roots and it's a horrific I don't
know you maybe not seen it but I see
that's one of my favorite in the
comedies it's [ __ ] horrible and you
see what can happen and what other
people can do it if you got black skin
and you look at that and you go that's
the thing that's available to me and
then that's part of my heritage and then
that Saddles you that paints you that
colors you and you carry that weight for
the rest of your life a little bit about
what that is you're his
three and you look at a movie like Black
Panther if you're a little kid and you
go [ __ ] I can be a king there can be
these these these different empowering
aspects that would give people that
really imprint I think on who we are and
I think it's a strange commentary in the
world just the fictional the comic book
can show a song I couldn't agree more I
mean the movie wasn't good but it
definitely resonated it was [ __ ]
great you should have a sign of cavemen
coffee open one up and just hat or your
new slogan should be came in copy black
chicks fell cavemen coffee we like we
like our coffee like we like our
customers black yeah can we get a
caveman coffee
Black Panther blend that's a movement
right there we meaning whom meaning
WorldStarHipHop we guys the big show
June 1st I will be at the cops comedy
club in San Francisco doing the Live
Nation presents the tinfoil hat comedy
night Eddie Bravo myself Trey's mala and
my homeboy Ryan Davis we're gonna be
doing I'm gonna be doing some man on the
street stuff with the people waiting in
line I'm gonna be we're going to do
we're doing stand-up then we're doing a
Q&A at the end and then whoever brings
the most people to the show gets a
private podcast in the back when myself
Eddie Bravo treads Ryan and you get to
smoke weed with Eddie Bravo so San
Francisco that's June 1st june 2nd we
are at to sacrament the punchline if we
sell out if we sell out cops Live
Nation's gonna put us on tour so please
come out we need 200 people to bring one
friend we can't do this holla at [ __ ]
boy so come on I'll help us out go to
Cobbs comedy club calm and buy some
tickets bring some friends let's get
weird one more announcement everybody
else in San Francisco that doesn't go to
that podcast and we didn't get to go
back and smoke weed with Eddie Bravo
everybody else in San Francisco will
also get that he Bravo
my dates out the date the out that out
the gates my mom's gonna read mom this
will be good okey-dokey oh look at you
you're adorable
he's Jason who is awesome by the way
thank you mom yes he is he's a [ __ ]
fart house all of Moon tober yeah that's
right what else am I gonna be mom he's
also gonna be at knock knock who's there
a black guy which is a black club in
Atlanta on the 23rd to the 50th of gloom
and as always don't forget to list them
to 92.7 the pod on iTunes or Spotify
thanks mom great job you make it sounds
interesting or get to put your podcast
on Google Play as well and anything
about that Google Play well do so the
whole I mean let's get into it the
celebration of life was great but let's
talk about what was really important
[ __ ] people having babies let's talk
about Notre Dame women's basketball
bringing home the freakin championship
and like you've been a fan forever yes
I'll take a holder correct season ticket
holder yeah bro eight what was that like
for you did you go to the final game no
well no that was in far away where was
it at it there's an Orleans my best
friend Roy is already looking into
season tickets for the NCAA next week
defend the championship well we only
lost two seniors so next year and all
those ACL injuries they redshirted them
so they'll all be back next year like to
your best players didn't wear hurt all
year right they had four now we got this
chick
and by the way female basketball players
are getting hot they're doing a hast
biasa what kind of world are we living
[Laughter]
I've noticed twelve-year-olds Ascari's
117 okay North Carolina like that what's
legal in North Carolina twelve Muffit
Muffit was watching yeah there was a
school they'll do that that's very
common in basketball is that crazy the
number one recruit is a white chick I
mean have you seen some of these
basketball players they're just they're
all girl ferb who was a am who they play
in the championship
no they play mr. McCowan yeah that
girl's like seven I mean she was huge
six seven they should what do you think
about lowering the rim so girls could
dunk just go some junk okay why wouldn't
you okay but why would you make it so it
looks exciting because that's like a
crowd pleaser and it's a shitty sport to
watch whoa dude you're like basketball
no I mean I'm just saying by numbers I
don't watch any basketball I only watch
i watch Kobe when he when he hears your
bamboo quit playing and now I watch that
one game and it was awesome as a great
game right listen Kobe was watching us
yeah purest talk okay okay stay in your
lane pirate all right so so next year
they should be even well they weren't
supposed to be good this year with all
those injuries and they so nobody
expected this to happen now so you were
just all we're gonna buy these season
tickets and I hope parties fun always
keep your season tickets cuz if you
throw them back then someone take them
then you thirteen thousand thirteen
thousand I think fifty nine or ninety
five or something like that they it
holds and it's almost always sold out I
bet I went to three or four games
everyone I went to sold the [ __ ] out
completely sold out that's awesome yeah
whenever I'm home and there's like a
game I'll just go all of South Bend
oh no it's a lot of old people a lot of
people
not very expensive won't worry where are
tickets I don't know couple bucks for
the whole season yeah that's good it
comes out to like seven dollars a game
or something yeah that's great yeah so
you had no clues gonna happen
no not that when did you think well
something might be special here well
they just kept getting better and better
and better so it has as a team you know
and I think it probably helped them that
they had to put people in different
positions that they're not used to play
in yeah that's one of those things with
everybody you step down you get injuries
early like I mean a couple of more like
preseason injuries like they didn't even
play game on so all your bench that are
young have to are forced to play you
know your six-man has to start you know
someone who wasn't gonna get playing
time at all now has to play eight nine
minutes a game so they do that all
season in the you know they just just
seemed like they gelled has ever been a
game where you have a lot of money
riding and you lose and you just get
violent yeah like then you just start
smacking people around no but when we
all of us the big fans were in our
respective homes during the game and
every time something happened I would
get like you know I'd be like you and my
phone is blowing up being on get like
nine text messages from all over the
country I think you're gonna jinx it if
you did that I don't pose it because all
of your friends expected to win and you
know it just kept getting better and
better and better it was awesome why
does people say all your friends are
degenerative scumbags is that like him
just well he knows him well thanks come
back we'll make some scumbag was the
parade like was it fun ticker-tape I did
not go why they came back they came back
I don't know it was like noon or
something else going on did you play
that I went to see the Eagles now
what is that we have bald eagles in the
park right by my house with a camera in
there so you want watch Eagles yeah
in a nest because they just had before
this biggest celebration in Notre Dame
woman's bad resin I think there were
maybe a couple thousand people on campus
when they cuz they're all what the
muscle came in yeah yeah yeah did you
play basketball
no you weren't down in the paint thrown
elbow get in people's faces my my sister
both extremely
unathletic not Jason sneaky athletic I
mean he does a bit about me bowling
that's about it well I love bowling
I love you I have a won contrary to his
act I have one bowling trophy and it was
last place champs that's great if you
can't win the joke is just that we had
bowling trophies in my house I didn't
say was for winning no yeah right
technically it still stands like
anybody's going to see Jason I
immediately start with the disclaimer
he's a liar when we walked in I go I go
listen mom a lot of people here there's
a lot of comedians here they can be
goofing with you a lot of might say oh
your money I owe them money you know and
they might try to shake you down just
write him a check they won't cash it
don't worry about it just part of the
joke mom did she go to you guys to a
comedy store last night now we went to
have dinner with her my aunt and my
uncle in law [ __ ] is this guy surprised
you still alive you're like he's gonna
be and I'm like yeah damn it oh you have
uncles and aunts and tell I they live in
Palm Springs I've one aunt lives in Palm
Springs and I have a cousin in San Diego
and have a cousin in Hermosa Beach area
Manhattan Beach oh yeah anywhere in that
neck of the woods so because she was in
town so I'm that kind of halfway like El
Segundo neck of the woods and had dinner
and stuff so we did that last night
do you hack I never going to see Jimmy
Kimmel after this
oh great who's there
don't even know not sure don't even know
we're gonna try to go last night and
then had dinner with family and [ __ ] man
so take her back to my he took Dana and
her mom there before so I've gone like
eight or nine times I saw Prince there
he got me in to see Prince oh yeah I was
on my biggest close to him Prince I was
probably from here that ATC son and I
was on the side of the stage on the
stage with all the guests this is
brother nice oh you couldn't even get
anywhere near him he had to to make you
look like me
yeah dude to make you look like me Oh
problem telling us what making you look
like me I tried on tattoos and he's
little but and all of his guitars right
there got to see all of his yeah the
same regular guitars it was awesome and
he's like oh you can't get in sorry I
can't get I saw him one time in the
streets like when I was like 20 and and
I was like that is the tiny and that's
all I saw I didn't notice him as Prince
I was like that's the smallest person
I've ever seen yeah he'll zoning also
short and he had heels on and he was
real diminutive slender like amazing
he's built like me if he if I was 5 foot
1 he's that good
he's short I like dude and not that odd
like your shoulders are too like all
that like they're you know your wait
till he's talking for that oh you're way
UV UV down the shoulders
mom mom turn the other way I'm but [ __ ]
my fist someone get this woman a tarp I
just kidding mom I'm gonna shoot it that
way um but and NEC still use that Donn's
I gonna I don't think I can get you in
on my [ __ ] and then he called me like 45
minutes before he's like if you can get
in 45 minutes I can get you in brow oh
yeah right never you know I've been
chased by police dogs where I would ran
slower than dude you should bring your
mom to the ding dog show it truly is I
would love to I would I mean she is like
a 6:00 a.m. flight to go to Mexico
tomorrow but I really wish I could have
gotten onto this trip are you worried
about being kidnapped a little but I
told them both the kids if I have to die
somewhere I would rather die poolside in
Cancun is that what they do after they
second prosecution
you don't go you're not going to the
pool I think I have you the water
they're going to get Montezuma's Revenge
they cancelled any outside excursions
and told everybody
max go right now yeah I'm supposed to go
down well there was a couple bombings
there's been a like a little terrorist
things that's a hate crime if you okay
here the guy what was his name
Maurice 14 murders in a 24-hour period
in kinko it's like and how many they
have in Chicago you know that makes
crazy how that will keep us out of a
country like well that will run through
a boy oh no there's rape and murder down
there and it's like no all our major
city is way worse
I know I live in South Bend Indiana and
we probably had that man when I hear
that you had 14 murders
I think cokes gonna be dude you're gonna
be able to get that coke for so cheap so
I want you to enjoy yourself don't do
all of it yeah you right after you had a
heart attack don't do coke long tell
listen I know you're trying to do it oh
she has a good story Oh family friend of
ours were on the uber on the way here
and I'm like hey how so-and-so doing and
a friend of ours I've known ever since I
was a kid one of my mom's best friends
well she's a nurse and she's donors
touchstone her nurse and she's been
nailed a couple times for pot and a
tested positive for Coke was I think who
has the but she's Union nurse so they
protect her and you know keep her in the
family and guide her through this and so
she's been through rehab once I think
and and they test her periodically so
she's looking for a job and the nursing
they offered her a job and the Nursing
Association pops up and says no she
can't hold up on that because she tested
positive for cochlear and screening and
she told me
that's not really possible because she's
been submitting synthetic urine for the
past year so she's been putting other
people's fake kit yes for a year and
that one got pest busted for Coach I
can't she can't fight it she can't be
like oh that's not me I'm totally clean
because I've you know all I'm doing is
smoking pot and then she get popped for
coke and she hadn't done coke inflect
forever perfect choices are five weeks
of in-house rehab or give up nursing
yeah we have doesn't seem that bad like
a lot of people if you were gonna go hey
you want to go to the spa in Mexico for
five weeks they go yeah you just treated
yeah depends on what kind of rehab
I guess there's like rehab yeah and then
there's like you have money we happened
and I yeah your than I like a room with
like 12 people in the same room you know
I mean yeah or like you're in a resort
I think she's given up like I need my
synthetic piss that will imagine all the
trouble we go to didn't I get over right
get somebody else's piss they get all
that piss for all that time and then be
like how long is coke in your sister's
car my bus coming for you
man that's telling you this yeah and
you're doing below you have it like five
six days before you start throwing some
[ __ ] real yeah but then how you get
more blow if you don't sell the piss
yeah it's like there's something there
doing piss your ass off for like three
or four days throw it in the fridge and
then mirela back and then four or five
days later then refilled of you know the
tank yeah I mean dude you got you have
great business plans oh thank you yeah I
appreciate that band let me ask you what
was Jason like as a young Christian
warrior it was quite a pain in the ass I
thought I resemble that mom I resemble
that mom we
we're like this is did you ever look
first right I remember my mom telling me
one time when he was maybe four and oh
maybe ten she said Oh peg this is he's
he's fast
no just remember we're not always as
fast as chase I remember with her she
had this [ __ ] violin or was your
sister's violin maybe but it was still
like from like when she was like a
teenager would be playing this and like
two violin lessons and then it just went
in the attic forever like one of those
things I was like oh [ __ ] violin you
know seven year old but a violin is the
I'd rather like hear sirens in
headphones than a seven year old [ __ ]
month it must sound like cats dying
right she let me do it as long as she
could stand God which was probably half
hour she was a generous woman and then
she's like that's the heart of them all
he's like honey you got to put that
thing away with my grandma she's like
honey you got to put that thing away
and I was like okay and then she took
and I did it again like got it back I
was playing for what and she violently
took it from me I didn't I put it
somewhere else and I was like you know
what
I couldn't been that loud I'm gonna
[ __ ] get this thing I'm just gonna go
upstairs shut the bedroom door start
fiddling away a little bit more in
privacy none the wiser
I love it say a violin like you're
playing pool it's a lot if it had been a
today that shows you how nice it sounded
so then the door kicks open the door
kicks open she just stand-in there with
the what the one weapon then I used to
get beaten with was what would wooden
spoon was the worst [ __ ] thing
in the world and she just stand there
with that wooden spoon yeah I'll sit on
the bed with this fiddle in my hand I'm
like ah [ __ ] like this Benny Hill sketch
were running around the bed when she's
swatting at my as hard as you can try to
get me I mean if I could have played
that on the fella tell us you to let me
in another hour I Pike and figured it
out I said crazy that's a crazy sweet
spot where you are not a where you think
where you learn I can get away from them
and now you start to run away instead of
just you have to take it at a certain
point and then at another point where
does it
where you go now I could leave but I
need to be respectful and just take it
like after your like yeah she's got a
shot he never got to that point
why did you beat me sword I used to get
spanked with a sword remember why you
have a big ass first grade six years old
seven years old me yeah your teacher
pulled me aside and said have him
executed sense of humor man she's like
right there with the here's the teachers
talking and he is the only kid in first
grade that starts to laugh cuz he gets
it and that was young I knew I was
allowed to speak like an adult at a
young age where yours all the time oh
don't then you had peers that were your
age I mean I kids and I hung out with
but I definitely hung out with a lot of
adults yeah and I think smart adults I
mean you guys were all when I look back
on my life I mean you guys were all
pretty much us you were 30 year old
stoners that were liberal and
progressive thinkers and all artists you
just happen to have a 12 year old and 10
year old hanging around you know I mean
I wasn't ever enamored with pot that
would you view that yeah how would you
put it though parenting you're like I
had a child I know as a mother but when
you look back at it as an adult you guys
were just as confused and scared as we
all are at that age now I mean it's
weird when I look back at it and I look
at my mom and I'm like god she was such
a leader looked up to like all that
stuff when you know I'm looking at her
through the eyes of a ten year old or a
14 year old or whatever it is but then
you you reference it now and you're like
wait so that was when she was 15 years
younger than I am right now or what like
whatever like this person you're still
looking up to that you're way beyond and
a lot like there's a weird ending makes
a time that happens well then well yeah
like if I would have lived your life and
and like back then when you have kids
when you're a lot younger I think people
are doing a lot less now I would have a
15 year old right now right you know I
mean your life would be so different a
story about this this family in India
and this lady had just had another baby
and so she could go to work with 90
makers does and they were living
underneath they were living underneath
the bridge like they had a shelter and
so she tells her like something like a
three-year-old
they she's gonna have to watch the 18
month old or whatever this little baby
is and that's who takes care of the baby
while mom goes to work it's like this
organism this human biology it's like if
it has to step up if the pressure is
great enough it [ __ ] achieve [ __ ]
it's just like the way the Internet is
like you see this happen and like
whatever a backflip on a motorcycle or
what John Jones can do in the cage or
you see any of that stuff and it's like
we get to excel beyond that
exponentially at a kind of an alarming
rate where I think it and the thing
about parenting is and everybody needs
to know this you just do the best you
can right and and when you're down and
and Jason turns around and looks back at
it you know he knows every moment like
that's gonna stick with them you know
what I see moms in grocery I see moms in
grocery stores with kids and I want to
say oh honey be careful cuz this turns
into a comedy act yeah flip me off and I
was like six
so J 7 was Jason funny from the gate yes
from the jump always I think I think
always but I think I was always around
funny adults I think I became funny I
don't know I don't know maybe I was a
funny kid I was always funny was he
always working blue was Jason working
blue from the get-go is he like
kindergarten dude's dick jokes yeah I
mean I remember I in kindergarten or
first grade I got in trouble because I
told a girl I wanted a humper when was
the first time you finger banged a lady
uh about 45 minutes oh that's great good
job Peggy Jane golden motor stance on
strong history of it upstairs baby that
wasn't a house
I thought you were talking well that was
wonderful what what what Johnny
don't ruin a wonderful nun and a mother
on their love a finger-blasting okay let
them have it yet I told a girl that I
wanted that I want those go I can
remember name but I I remember I got in
trouble for her gotta call the
principal's office and I was like [ __ ] I
hope I don't there's like first grade
and then I walked home and that's four
we got reverse bust we were close to
walking we know we can walk and so walk
home and I get home and I'm like you
don't say [ __ ] to me and I can't cool
man I'm in the clear less about half
hour 45 minutes go by makes me like a
after-school snack sitting there and
eating it and she goes so and here you
want to hump Kelly wiggler or whatever
your name is
she's at school called just brought up
casually I'm just eating Cheerios like
okay I don't know what that word means
they told me what it means I guess I had
it all wrong I [ __ ] knew it it man
I wanted to hump that [ __ ] how early
did you get sexual I was early I was a
button first grade
yeah I don't I mean that sounds more
like a sex crime yeah not even close to
that any kind not even close to that I
don't think I don't think anybody I mean
you say that casually like everybody
else would be like oh yeah before that
four years before that same neighborhood
how old was the guy Sam the whole room
is full of zingers today wow what a fun
show what a fun show guys we are in
there we are in now in the NBA playoffs
baseball I mean we have I guess you
maybe make bets I didn't come out on the
NBA pull that hold on I think I'm out
okay I don't know I mean I don't there's
nobody in there that I really am caring
too much for I'd like to see good series
but I'm just and there's not that many I
respect that but I also respect bet dsi
for all your Betty needs go to Betty
aside calm for all your bad knees use a
promo code punch
25 and you'll get 25 hard cold dollars a
man it's gonna be a tough NBA playoffs
to bet on a lot of crazy things guys
love it
baseball is crazy some good fights
coming up - to bet on what's the next
big UFC we got to do another UFC party
that was a lot of fun it we will tweak
it
well tweak yeah and make it yeah make
everybody have to come and maybe we'll
get maybe we'll have like we'll get them
to have like cuz they're very kind but I
think we could spread that kindness and
have them maybe have some drink specials
you know people come over to our side
yeah I don't have like drink or food
specials yeah just to entice more people
to come down but you go to bed DSi you
use the promo code and bam you're met
you're making bets I do a five fight
parlay every single fight I mean I
everyone but the big pay big and at our
UFC event that we went to we were
announcing how our fights are all going
in yeah again I got everyone but one I'm
getting four out five every time I think
you should also get money on a par life
you get none of them right hmm I think
that's something that you can bat I
think that's a side bet that you can
make right I don't think that's an
actual side bet that you can make I've
done that before it got everyone wrong
and everyone just killed me on it but
bet the acai it's just as hard as
getting him all right our best our
longest running sponsors and we love
them very much
I always see people at the store improv
or wherever and people come up to their
fans of our show and every one thing
they always say is they've all used
Betty si and they're still using it a
lot I'm gonna say they're still using it
one thing I want to do is what you get
in you realize hey man I went a couple
bets now I'm in the pluses now I make
money and you can use Jason Tebow's
betting uh he's got he's got a plans
he's got schemes he knows how the
variable of gambling I'm a good at
blackjack
yeah that's your thing right but I'm not
you know I'm asking for anything else
sports betting for me I love to do it
but I'm always like I guess I kind of
break even every now and then I've never
really lost big
I don't really bet big I love parlays
I'm just like you I'd like to bet ten
twenty bucks on something specially the
NFL especially NFL NFL I was doing ten
team are ten dollar parlays every time
try to get six right I mean you get to
parlays and put it to you this way but
bass football season if you get one or
two four parlay 14 parlors which isn't
that hard to do in the NFL you cover
your bedding for the entire season if
you do 10 or $20 bets you your entire
gambling now is playing the house is not
how you formulate your shoes now you're
playing with house money in football
season if I can hit one I I'll break
even at least on the year kind of like
drug dealing like one or two eight balls
to rest your coat for the rest of the
year it's free you don't do very much
coke then I know real quick Johnny key
you look up our YouTube page real quick
because Johnny's been doing a great job
on this YouTube page I don't know if you
guys have seen Johnny's work on it but
Johnny I also call in if I don't know if
the numbers on the bottom line but we'll
take calls we will in the last up you
know half hour 45 minutes feel free to
be kind to my mom but you know her
answer you know my mom's not [ __ ]
around with any of these stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] right mom I'm sorry I'm sorry
with these darn [ __ ] right mom got that
joking last night while we're watching
TV I'm like ari is about to get peed on
right there let's go to right let's fast
or - are you getting peed on now my
favourite thing is I'm middle of talking
I notice I but I turn you can see me
turn and look at Stanhope and I realize
his dick is out here he comes behind our
look at my reaction man Sam's reactions
are awesome I love Ari's only problem is
these are my only pants these are my
only jeans Anatomy jeans go buy some new
ones you do I'm sorry but we rocked that
show that was the best we put that was
so much for zone that was in Arizona
scroll back up here here does it get
close Aaron yes sir would you say that
we were probably the most significant
moment of that that that festival
certainly in the podcast studio sneak up
here cons oh that's just a preview yeah
that was great
that was super fun the next day we had
our big all things comedy lunch you know
everybody was there at the big luncheon
thing and that's the first time I saw
magical and he came out to me and he
goes what the hell happened in the
studio just fire crackers everywhere
everything's turned upside down
there's pee all over the place we're
like hey bro we had a podcast here we
had a podcast we scare him I think he
just doesn't understand we don't you
know I get a lot of requests tape for
you and Brody to be back together have a
reunion show that was another one that
was crazy I know what's going on this is
ascendant Sam threw a tantrum written
something that time to write you know no
I had to go all is a mentally to the
first hour how'd you do it Comedy
Central like this is great no safety at
all yeah I would say I want to I don't
know if you ever yeah I buy tantrums yes
please talk to me I need to give a
motherly advice where studios this who
is that over there
[Music]
Matt knows that's not mad no sets James
this is where you tell him to kill
himself you're adding notes go home I'm
not sorry that I'm hurting you get the
[ __ ] out of here leave just leave if
you're not gonna help fix the [ __ ]
phones or leave you were just a
distraction get the [ __ ] down all you do
is give us bad drops get the [ __ ] out
fix it
we're moving to fix it or get out it's
true one day on go home get the [ __ ] out
and go home you understand me you [ __ ]
over show two weeks in a row get the
[ __ ] out and go home go talk to your
boss we don't want you anymore if you're
watching this feel free to not call that
number that was a great club
it was in the worst area how real was
that good
who's aged horribly since I was real I
was just saying earlier my mom was
talking really I'm like time has not
been well to me any of us time is hot
been well like even Johnny you look
better the other day when I saw you they
need you right now so even in just two
days
Tate actually it's not true Tate time
has been very kind to you thanks I'm
really kind of time how do how would one
be kind to time what could I do to be
kinder at a time like there's a little
we'll go over after we're gonna have
lunch it's all it's all the same stuff
you've heard over and over again just be
kind just be sweeter sweeter the time
treat the Lord with respect more sweet
tea do you think I take that they
disrespect ah the heavyweight champ in
the UFC steep bay yeah why what did it
means do you think he doesn't get as
much press and play and push from the
UFC let's say it's like a Conor or
somebody else I mean I mean he's a bad
man i sorry talking Cormier versus um I
think it's Rossiter they're not even
talking about Miocic I think that his um
I think that division is just not an
exciting division I think he's great in
that division but does what three four
five heavyweights that they weren't
really relevant right now boxing is more
relevant in the heavyweight right now in
the UFC
great for a long time UFC was way more
relevant in heavyweight than boxing you
got to say though the boxing is more
relevant right now probably and due to
like shows like Brendan's and Joe's it's
like that kind of stuff has brought up
people's interest in boxing well also
the heavyweight division has their
interest for undefeated people well the
you of
see that to make good fight the
competition is brought up as well these
problem is that they're trying to run
the UFC like they run a network which is
pay talent as little as possible and
keep a lot by a network that is anymore
I mean I think it had been that and
that's what they did do a number so that
they could get a huge huge selling price
to the buyer I just think that beyond
then the buyer is now going upside down
on another lever I just think that the
the the Reebok deal did a lot of damage
to or see a lot of jams yeah that was
like almost like it was almost like a
bad PR move in a way mom if Tate and I
were to get into a fight who do you
think would win B and [ __ ] be honest
and I'm a man Triple E here helping me
by helping I'll be like hey dude I mean
we can give you the old like Tripoli's
on his hands and knees behind you and
you don't know it and I come over and
he'd do that up you ever heard of a hype
man I'm a psyched man I just sit there
and tell JC's doing great to keep doing
what he's doing yeah the tate is slowing
down and then when he looks over at me
he gives me a no wink wink let's take a
call I love there know what Rhonda's
doing did you see her in the WWE that's
a really [ __ ] [ __ ] up in hi your
honor with pain
Webster and PEG tube ampeg pack Webb's
only known or twenty years literally
known or 20 years yeah thank you coming
up wow this is not working out for me
what do you mean you can't hear it we
can't win here I'm I can hear but I'm
talking over and I have my own echo back
yeah turn your [ __ ] down your computer
down I'm just on the phone no I'm just
going to say Nick V air suspension is
about to be taken now and over to be
over middleweight or welterweight
division so you think it's gonna be it's
coming to an end right and he's gonna
fight again
April 19th so and you want do you think
he fights 170 or 185 tape I don't mean
and is
to fight in the UFC Oh 100% I don't know
I mean he's like I think he's really
teased in the boxing world too and going
like I'll scrap here too you know I mean
because that was before that a couple
years ago that was his only interest
he's like boxing is the only place where
combat athletes are getting proper
payment and so I think I'll just I'll
hold up for that so I think it's what's
a nice position he can do anything he's
open to do anything and now I think that
laws are changing to make athletes like
Nick more safe in the UFC and in combat
we we yeah yeah and any coincidence to
the fact that his suspension ends the
day before for 20 I think the brown I
just wing such we're in Canada are you
calling from I'm not in Canada in South
Texas right along the Mexican border I
got the brownish weed yeah stems in it
dude and like concedes where you got to
do lawn maintenance on your weed
corncobs you can get like avocados
anywhere at any time in the [ __ ] year
doesn't matter but like just a couple
states away it's like not it's still
1978 here for the weed yeah my buddy
mowed a lawn for a quarter pound just a
week ago oh that's a big lawn that is a
big lawn yeah I don't know how long my
lawn will have to be [ __ ] huge my you
don't want to give you a quarter pound
mow it like my mine do better my buddy
mowed New Mexico I'm free I'm free I'm
giving you a quarter pound it's like I'm
framing you because there's like a body
that I buried in that yard and I'm gonna
be like hey that guy just wearing this
guy with a lawn mower
hey dude thanks for calling in dude I
don't know I would you guys watch again
later but thanks would you guys watch a
Connor versus Diaz boxing match no I
would for sure I would for me and I
would but I don't give it any gravity
I'd rather much rather see them scrap I
mean would you watch Michael Jordan in
his prime and and so you won't be in
Kobe and his Highness
have a three-point contest sure but I'd
love to see him play one-on-one I mean
I'd like to see all ah I guess I think
that's different boxing still beating
the [ __ ] out of each other yeah but
they're both such good kickers and a
jiu-jitsu and wrestling and all that
[ __ ] talking would be insane I think
it'd be insane if you're not saying I
want more I want all of it I want all of
that
how about and that's the problem that's
different those guys are fired up in
that way and they're scrappy in that way
and like it's like guys like steep pay
or there's a lot of guys that are like
more like rose namajunas isn't anywhere
near the star that she could be because
of the way she carries herself she
carries herself with honor integrity and
dignity and that's how she walks through
the [ __ ] life and and regardless of
what fans what three out of the hundred
or whatever the ratio is of people that
care for that actually care for it will
put money towards that and effort and
love and shine as opposed to somebody
that is yelling and making an ass of
themselves and attacking other people
weapon bull get one that's crazy oh
you're on would take Fletcher
what is this tall taller title what is
this hi ty what's up will you come from
Ty Ty tall tall okay you had a good time
you think you're staying out for a
minute
I think we just got hacked I think that
was a rush I'm pretty sure that was a
rare how's the marriage going Bob you
dog I got an update on Aaron's marriage
by slamming it hard I ran an errand at
The Comedy Store right and he was with
the lovely lady did not look like the
last few ladies behind him with no it
was we got momma T so good what's up
buddy how are you thank you just doing
the same ol weekly deal
oh nice so what is it what does that
entail this is your weekend tell my mom
just asked if that's masturbating yeah
area code fam eight five nine that's a
oh that's upstate New York is it I don't
know it is it is nice where were you at
where you
oh I'm down and I'm living the Orleans
now I'm wondering about these pelicans
in the playoff I like them I mean
Anthony Davis is obviously better than
everybody on Portland but Portland I
think has bad death I mean like they
have the number one best player and then
Portland has the next three best players
and then then New Orleans has another
great player you know him did you see
the triple doubles he was putting up for
like goddamn near a month and a half
well I did I said anthea Davis is great
what are you talking about that's what
I'm just saying I couldn't believe it I
was sitting here watching it in Orleans
it I was like when is it gonna stop
he's the best dude that kid if he wasn't
wasn't so lanky and that's his problem
he goes down he bangs and he's just
super lanky
that's why Shaq was great because he had
that same size they all do but I extra
150 pounds huge yeah he had tree trunks
empty Davis is like more as built like a
spread five and he has to go down and he
set to pick he can bang his knees and he
gets hurt he's still growing into the
body to this day with booking boogie
going out
I still call them the UK Wildcats
they're like [ __ ] four Wildcats on
the team let me ask the same thing are
they talking about resigning this guy
that's the big deal is the second time
[Music]
interesting dude it's gonna be
interesting man I they're playing better
without him but he's just an all world
player he's somewhere like San Antonio
with attitude I like the [ __ ] fiery
brings to the [ __ ] it's like it's like I
haven't the fam Tripoli on the pain this
guy caller of the mayor point yeah good
job Johnny
haha that was good
finally someone's not executive in here
executive move of the year okay we've
gave in Johnny too much power
well we turn we're ready for that call
we return about to right before that
camera ah oh that's right Aaron's update
on Aaron's marriage yeah talk to me uh
see him at the store I thought you know
by the way Aaron hates black comedy we
found out yeah I heard that too
[ __ ] hates when black people do calm
well then don't come see me at knock
knock who's there black guy because
that's a dark that's a it's a it's a
black Club it's like this [ __ ] black
guy got up it was just ha ha ha
and they Bruno's ruined a perfectly good
white show any storm doll which is white
women yeah I didn't even so I'm like hey
nice to meet you you know cuz I didn't
want to blow up his spot cuz every time
I see him he's with a different
dimepiece yeah and he's like oh you know
my wife and it kind of gives me that
wink wink like just be cool kind of
thing of course I do
she's all over me man oh I thought that
was a wink that I hate no don't say
you've seen me you know repeatedly here
with multiple multitude of women yes and
then and then he's like oh can you I'm
gonna go to the restroom real quick
she's all over me man oh she doing kept
kissing my hand kiss both my hand so I
just start to loosen her way up my arm
she doing any start in the law no I was
like that Tom and Jerry we kissed the
hand and keeps kissing all the way up
you know to mean to the shoulder and she
started giving like a little peck on the
neck and I go hey now Aaron's coming
back
maybe her Aaron looks like a [ __ ] I mean
he might be in a she's like wait you
said no or you said not now you're in
the face bro she I said wait you said no
or not now yeah and I go I don't
remember what I said but whatever I said
I stand by it
hey we're at the five five nine yaw with
tape Fletcher this punch truck
yes yeah ah depend all right [ __ ] a
awesome what do you guys think the
Niners gonna do this here this up good I
think they're gonna be good I mean the
problem is
are in that division but the Rams are
the Niners look good I think bi they'll
finish second that division could be a
wild-card team and they got a lotta
money yeah we'll make the playoffs er I
think yeah I think they could be a
wild-card team it depends it depends on
that an hour division Johnny the NFC
South I mean Caroline is gonna be right
there again at New Orleans Atlanta Tampa
I mean three teams could come out of
there so I mean as long as one team
comes out of there
I don't think two teams come out of the
central I don't think two teams come out
of the east
what about it for San Francisco goes
after Odell Beckham and then Hugo ham
tenderloin and get his gay on I hear
that they're going out to Dez I'm not a
big fan of that move I hope we don't get
him I didn't even want Richard Sherman
to be honest but they are gonna sold me
on it do you want time do you want dez
bryant that's a that's another rumor
I've heard ha not really I mean not I
don't like guys with big attitude you
know what I mean just just go he's about
to be 30 hit off you know he's about to
be 30 yeah do you think he's at a place
right now where he's more like go down
the middle type guy like Terrell Owens
he's gonna be your second option yeah
exactly right that's exactly who he is
yeah yeah you want it you want him to go
somewhere where it's like they're they
got a speedy guy on the outside but now
you gotta put somebody on Dez pack your
thoughts on weird guys cause I'm busy
doing killing this guy do I get any love
I will say that I'll give you love I'm
sorry
all right here's what's doing that I
even wrote down to my notes whose words
with their phone Sam or mom right there
I wrote that in mom that doesn't look
like mom mom right there okay
because literally over I'm trying to
tell her Ari's in I believe nope yeah
that's right he's deep in it's 4:00 a.m.
there instead of 2:00 a.m. and he's like
man I could do the 2:00 a.m. before Am's
pretty careless I didn't really want to
see his junk oh you don't like seeing
that Aaron and I did have it set up and
kick you that I know Sam we'll just
Molly welcome thank you I know he's
hiding from him you know what
what kind of word is Molly Wow Molly one
word that's a great word Tripta Magoo
you know I'm saying is he Sam keeps
watching on the back real fan of the
show would you feed her lines already I
watched the show one word all right
thanks for calling me thanks brother
you're the best man good luck with your
Niners halls and wrote - good luck with
your Niners um Tate what you got any
movies coming up right now you're gonna
be in West will in the new one because
I'm sorry posted a be the third one no
see the third season and I think it
makes sense to bring me back because
they've wrapped on the second obviously
yeah yeah like we make total sense but I
know this one is is I don't like
features a lot of spoiler alert
a lot of samurai there's a samurais
section in season two and there's some
and it features a lot of like the
characters like that have gotten out or
trying to get out to the real or so I
don't think it's focused as much as west
as right as it has been the whole
corporation that's dude smashing the
rock when you put the makeup on you yeah
the one on the right that's what eight
looks like when he wakes up in the
morning that's my that's his last day of
doing [ __ ] drugs right there that's
what K looked like that's why I got
sober right there look at that it was
like four different heads that they did
really how long did that take up
successions you know if you keep those
no they're in a warehouse the Christian
Tinsley is a makeup artist that does all
this and he does how did they do that
they mold your whole day they mold my
whole head and you had to sit there for
like 20 hours or some [ __ ] because if
fleshlight offered those whose flesh
lights there's a good market for that if
judging from my DMS for sure oh I got a
great idea I got a great business idea
don't anybody steal this this this is
sure way to keep it down here's what you
do because I was thinking well it would
be so funny like you know it'd be funny
like if you made a glory hole okay
outside of a toilet so far outside of a
toilet outside the toilet what does that
mean outside of it cuz next as a whole
yeah it's like right next to like a
where so I'm sitting on a toilet glory
holes right here with a toilet
would be I remove the toilet paper
dispenser stick my dick in there and put
the toilet paper roll on my dick and
just wait hmm I don't think you like it
just pulling yeah I think that's but
once a switches surprise true true
yeah prize it's a long erection oh you
only put like one or two likes pieces of
toilet paper on you don't have a whole
roll feel like we're doing then when you
pull it off and then I gotta take that
off we're gonna take the thing off so
sucked in that dish yeah dude
what a great business idea it's a
business opportunity for you it's a lot
of excessive stuff to get into what I'm
there for which is a mouthful of taking
a [ __ ] while I suck a dick that is true
but it's more for the ones who made oh
snaps dude if you got streamlined that
thing he's hot so efficient I also think
this is a funny joke
where it's like you at home you remove
your toilet paper dispenser yeah and
then you paint like a black circle so it
looks like a hall and then you drill a
[ __ ] dildo into it and then you put
your toilet paper roll on it better so
then it looks like a glory hole on the
other side here's why will you just get
the wide you ain't drilling why not get
those really cool advanced things they
get the suction cup because I think
they've all created them suction cup
dildos yeah because what I'm gonna pay
per wall you got tile wall yeah I mean
when I'm gonna do that dang fix what I
plan to do to that thing I don't think a
suction cups gonna hold it like what do
you plan to do I'm just gonna give it a
hand job with my house hole okay like
dude I bet you your [ __ ] it's kind of
like an anaconda we're just unhinges and
more of a Venus flytrap Venus flytrap
but yeah anyways welcome to punch drunk
mom those were dreams get expressed yes
I guess so what are you you haven't even
coming you audition for anything cool or
everything on our way here my mom's like
the center of rock just been in classes
Jumanji did right good I've been doing
most of my stuff is just like trying to
practice memorization so that I can look
a lot of a lot of difference let's do a
clean scene right now
I don't think so sick okay I don't want
to do a scene from Willy Wonka okay like
that what do you want to do uh I want
you to be a have you here's a funny
thing like any acting stands ever done
I can't imagine you ever
nicholae really being off-book on
something I'm not even off-book on your
friends names I mean [ __ ] weirdness
man okay
Oh Johnny's pulling up some scenes for
you I'm will your willy wonka I'm your
the Chocolate Factory
do ya I just want to say a weird I don't
know if you guys saw but Waco was really
good on that okay you were like Waco
yeah it was really good you play as a
would you play a biker biker
meth-dealing biker I don't think they
had method in Waco they course they did
it's wake up that's what Waco is Chinese
for meth is that right yeah it's
actually known established by the
Chinese
that guy's a great actor the one on the
bottom both all those guys is so intense
right so can we all agree the government
[ __ ] Waco over up well yeah I mean he
was no Koresh is no saint but who is
Aaron you'd like to get cocked at the
Comedy Store was marrying young girls
but yeah that Bill Hicks yeah I mean
it's Pierce he's got our way over here
my mom's like am I ever gonna see tater
in a movie where he doesn't get killed
by the star of the movie incoming I
didn't I think oh he was let go hey how
many movies have you not died in maybe
some things you haven't no idea really
you've worked so much that you have one
of those things where people don't
believe that people get like that we
like I don't even remember everything
I've done you know you you see like um
right what's a girl that won all the
Academy Awards Marilyn Marilyn Streep
was being interviewed by curling being
know all right that's why people love
this I know like I actually couldn't
think of somebody's name I asked Sam and
I just blindly trusted that that's what
it was right Paige Paige Paige Paige
Webster um what am I an [ __ ] yeah
with that reversal vote situation anyway
everybody comes to a consensus on
chemistry I saw her being interviewed
and she couldn't even name all of the
movies in 60 seconds that she was
nominated for or one crazy
that's insane well yeah I mean she is
crazy
I mean she's batshit crazy I don't know
where I hit hard that's confusing
da Hye why is that confusing so angry
Arden know you don't know this but she
looks just like my mom so it's so
obvious there we go I'd bang your mom
Jung up pictures of your mom welcome to
pegs world
welcome to pegs world yeah the impact
will run a [ __ ] train on your mom and
there it is it's a world of pegging a
world of packet that's your own porn
line look at her how hot she was that's
before the MK ULTRA on that yeah
remember that what's your favorite movie
of all time buddy I'll go with like a
kill a mockingbird or a godfather
I love taxi driver if I watch out the
other day it is so relevant to today
it's unbelievable it's kind of hard
because there's so many different
categories I mean I love the movie
contact five Caddyshack he's always it
stands the test of time there are songs
out here and I'm a little automatically
remind me of just that ever be any great
like adult comedies again sure totally
I feel like we're right for it
especially with all the oppression
that's happening right now where people
are trying to posture and signal
everywhere and it's like there's a few
smart people that will rise up out of
that and really [ __ ] just
molly-whopped the whole industry with
some new comedy that really lays people
to waste and puts all the dummies who
all think everybody should have a voice
because you call this episode male while
it's crazy it's crazy and so then you
get those people go no here's what a
real measure decisive voice that's
thoughtful on all these different topics
is putting out it's like that's the nice
thing that comics are I think are really
interesting the way that they they've
been fed up early on I mean they're like
there's a sadness in that but it's like
I'm gonna die if I don't express all the
frustrations that I see about all the
[ __ ] constructs
going on in the world and and for you
guys to be able to do that and then find
humor out of that so that you can
survive for your very survival it's like
that's really when I look at comedy
that's kind of what I think I'm seeing a
lot of the time you know yeah and it's
in [ __ ] it's important because in
that when you guys crack through that
cracks through for the rest of the world
there's also like a lot of like who you
speaking to because you can make a
comedy for the masses that's for the
lack of a better term cookie cutter or
you know if you're a comedy connoisseur
or a writer or performer where you like
you see it all coming but I don't say
for like a better turns the dummies
you know the masses just the people are
like oh I want to go see this I know
Kevin Hart oh look you know whatever the
[ __ ] right but the people that make
movies for not that way like almost how
they did um
get out right you know that wasn't a
typical horror movie that was that was
there's not out there for normal [ __ ]
from really caught fire for being a
smart movie that's done by not the
industry I mean you know he really
wasn't somebody was a huge filmmaker at
the time and it just caught fire and I
think there'll be a comedy that'll have
that same sort of effect and I feel like
they they won't let comedy just become
and there's so many rules to it and it's
gonna have to be done and just like
podcasting where it's gonna have to be
independent and just put out there and
just have to bear the blunt of the
political correctness like you know it's
like airplane you could never do an
airplane right now that's things so
quickly and correct you could but you
have to be willing to go through it and
just be like no this is [ __ ] funny
well the problem is everybody that's in
the creative aspect of that and all the
performers and all the actors and the
writers and directors they are totally
willing to go through it it's the studio
that fronts the money that cycle we
don't want it you know we got a lot of
[ __ ] to [ __ ]
it's got all those like all things
comedy like you gotta [ __ ] quit
getting Ari's dick out on YouTube
because hey we don't care if you guys
but you're gonna flag the whole [ __ ]
Network like they're gonna take all
things comedies YouTube page down not
just punch string is is that and the
studio has that kind of thing but you
want to do a thing like airplane I mean
it's a different sure we're more
comedies different more present to the
consequences that everything is
you know what I mean yes like it's it's
like everything's heavier the stakes are
higher and so you can't you can't have
an Archie Bunker or something like that
in that same I mean it's like it has to
grow and evolve I'm not gonna sit here
and and and boom on the fact that like
some things aren't appropriate anymore
but it's like there's a time when I mean
not long ago I remember Rogen telling me
about trying like we met this girl and
she was black and he's like he was on
news radio with me we were supposed to
have a make-out scene we filmed it all
and the country wasn't ready for it so
it never came to air because they were
scared of it wasn't mine and that was in
1998 like that to me at the time he told
me in like oh 4 or whatever that is like
that's like modern times like what the
[ __ ] is going on
yeah but we're like that everywhere you
know and it's not it's just we coddle
people a lot and then you know we I mean
think about this Bay and there's no they
doesn't have a spine or don't in the 90s
in the 90s a woman that paid for every
shitty people green grandpa everybody
and that was a hero James Kirk James
Kirk always like to Sam Tripoli of outer
space I don't know thank you the best
and worst podcast I've been on in a long
time
I mean after this factor this in the 90s
in the 90s you know my mom's one of them
who paid for everything our entire
childhood couldn't claim my sister and I
as a tax exemption although she was
putting us through college
she couldn't we get any tax breaks and
that was why not because they're not
they're not legally made that's not even
the bad they weren't anything so she
couldn't claim as part of that stuff can
legally adopt me couldn't legally adopt
me back in the day we can legally get
married and if we can other couldn't be
in those so even though we're a family
unit they didn't get the benefits that
all other Americans got as a family you
know no wonder that in monkey berries in
my game I heard it was held back for
insurance reasons
sure that's interesting of course it's
always pop you don't want to pony up on
any of that talk about more they didn't
factor in how much money there's gonna
be made on gay divorce they should have
been made it like we're gonna legalize
gay divorce by the way I read an illegal
in this game here at first but lawyers
get behind this game things I want to
lose half their [ __ ] - how funny was in
a pizza place wouldn't do gay marriage
like what gay people are getting pizza I
thought it was okay
was no there was a there was a pizza
place to crazy
Indiana just passed just I mean within
the last month or so black people voting
past no liquor sales on Sunday to get to
marijuana for Christ's sake I was doing
crackers and they were like oh yeah we
gotta do Sunday show I go but I thought
booze is illegal on safe okay yeah they
are get in a restaurant then why am I
here I'm only here to sling drinks no
you can go to bought you ain't gonna
bars you just can't buy it for like your
house yeah buy packages yeah no you can
buy it in restaurants and bars
you just can't if they serve you can't
go yeah cuz we used to live right on
Lake Michigan so on Sundays we're out of
[ __ ] right drive ten minutes ten
minutes to Michigan and take a stab on
Sundays how much a 12-pack is in
Michigan that's a lie right on the
border that's like 28 bucks guess how
much it is Monday like 13 bucks let me
ask you so I'm saying is you're drinking
nice beer how much cuz you could get
like a Falstaff or something you could
get like a Pfeiffer they like that would
have been a box four bucks for a case
hey how much do you think the guy who
owns the pizza shop that won't cater
minglang's how much do you think he
loves dick like a lot like oh they
always seem to like a whole lot like
there's no reason to hate anybody who
hasn't done anything to you that much
unless you're really jealous of what
they're doing no it was a guy to I feel
like if your business does am I gonna do
whatever I don't give a [ __ ] very much
but what I would like mandatory is that
I would like to know that if that's your
choice that you stand like that so you
need to put a sign like that in your
place so I know whether to patronize
your place or not of course like I'd
rather know who the racists and who the
I'd rather know who everybody is like
don't know I go that would be great
our governor Governor Mike Pence was a
hundred percent behind that loved it
Behindwoods
who is now the vice president
unbelievable believe that's how you know
it's all [ __ ] dude
it's just all [ __ ] I love that idea
tape there should be like you should
have like [ __ ] like almost like a
barbershop of stripes like gay people in
but all these people will get ABC
outside your restaurant might as well
let me know are you and I humanity
scared yeah
who are you press against yeah what do
you think it's less human than you yeah
I would like to know who that is I love
that because if we agree look at this
guy's like watery I'm like I'll eat here
- I agree with you buddy they raised a
quarter of a million dollars to keep a
racist place open yeah guys I don't
think gay people should have pizza
either I want I wanna record podcasts no
case on this podcast get mad there's
only like four game arms off podcast
please donate to our GoFundMe here woman
I'm retired
she's being prepared in everybody no no
still on the team you play I'll feel
more in the bench right now tape my mama
as a coffee question researchers looked
at Craig Robinson and Jack night uh what
explain nitro coffee to my mother tape I
was telling her about it and she said
what's the difference I'm like mmm it's
just it's a it's a process by which we
care good and can our coffees and you
just infuse it with nitrogen and then
also the coffee itself is interviews so
we can it with nitrogen and then we also
infuse the coffee nitrogen and it
changes the palate a little bit of the
temperature like it'll make it a little
softer and a little smoother on the
tongue and so it's a it's more of a
taste thing I'd like to try that yeah
mm-hmm that's what it is right there
yeah okay man Coffee cocom using punch
I'll get you 10% off that cold brew is
just like there's no acidity to it it
takes all that off of it so we do like a
hibiscus tea too which is a real tart
but since it's cold brewed there's a
sweetness to it so it kind of changes
the nature of the fruit or element that
you're dealing with
cool fun why'd you turn a coffee man or
not what we're still poor come baseball
tear you baseball guy I love all that
stuff sports for me is really where it's
at you don't like any sports except for
punching people no I like I like that I
like never answer to me why I gotta go
laughing at a woman's are we on the team
back here again
well piggy Webster I'm sorry I'm
insulted my own mother doesn't even
believe me in a fist fight for my to the
death I remember every rapper one time I
came home you must have been like early
high school and you had a game of touch
football going on oh yeah because
they're all my front like tape all my
friends are huge back then got out of a
car and yelled don't hurt him
yeah that always helps you in when
you're in high school yeah well that
could rubberband no or you just bounce
back up like you you wouldn't never get
hurt come get a lady who beat you with
swords it's like don't bank me with
swords oh okay that's a different how
badass is that yeah I'm such a Conan fan
that she's got the broadsword she's like
you know what this thing is useful yeah
okay what are we doing right now what
are we doing right now
thank you that's pretty dope there he is
Jason couldn't haul Jason can haul he's
such a Christian warrior Arirang Arirang
zan he's shirtless and literally his
tits flip into the back his nipples
literally hit up at the top of his
shoulder he does love nudity he's well
he's got no he's got no bad angles yes
he eats pretty good
yeah he's helped his [ __ ] he looks like
he's got it the Holocaust survivor right
there later powerful as wheels are just
escaped from Dustin he's like freedom he
look talk about freedom yeah he looks
like a like a melting candle that's
running from a fire he's beautiful look
at that a champion yeah he sure is
he's got those shitty Marilyn
[ __ ] he's so proud of yourself too so
he so he says oh dude that's just rude
he's asked he asks where ever he goes
though it's Universal it's not
favoritism first-run every other day
every night time I'm fast in you suck my
dick man why do we go suck your dick
dude
who gets the suckers dicks anyone anyone
pretty much yeah
and actually that has been proven to be
true they let anybody do I pretty much
would - really yeah so cars did I mean
I'd let already suck my dick
oh you let anybody suck your dick I
really would it's now really like I
stretch it's kind of just how it is no
gay ship which is but stuff but you want
sloppy go for what about drive-thru what
about a drive-thru glory hole that's
another idea I love that dude drive-thru
but if somebody's been drinking though
and then they don't not quick they
[ __ ] near look this athlete look at
me just fighting for [ __ ] yards like
a like a [ __ ] running back seeing
holes thirst holes
looks like you're writing for grey shoes
are untied it looks like a treadmill
going backwards probably goddamn it
looks like guarantee you Candice didn't
make a face that big at 10:22 on [ __ ]
Sunday night she didn't look like she is
a little insane rude man this has been
the best worst podcast I've ever done in
my life thank you guys I'll win just by
by jumping in the race I think we all
are winners dude I didn't say that I
mean just this okay look at that face
that's perfect so that's a face of
determination yeah
that is the exact I love you that's
exact same face Candice me never gonna
give you up never gonna let you down
that's what I'm saying right there is
that right that doesn't look like it
funny cargo pants - could you take that
call take it oh come on dude who is it
we want to take calls man the people
want to talk
oh you're not a Mike please please how
many views that guy yeah tall hauls back
this can't be
hey dude tall tall tight I told ya what
is up what's up are you there
bye Felicia
we tried we tried next up anybody else
yeah just guy never gonna throw at him
and another one was coming in hey yo
have you gone back up on stage students
stand up we talked about it
no I've just been out like I said I just
been kind of honing my craft on stage in
other ways but I haven't been nah I
haven't put anything I've been working
so much at just auditioning and getting
out there that
yep together again to put together
something to go on stage I haven't done
I haven't put any effort 6:3 yo where
are you calling from and what the [ __ ]
do you want
Illinois House weather Colorado ah it's
been raining pretty shitty cuz we can
get canceled your chair so it's
convenient excuse to avoid that beatdown
you're gonna get Tony Santa's Tommy
buddy so what's up with her I'm like BAM
I just want to say man I love you guys
Sam I just listened to the podcast with
army guys with the NASCAR that's it was
awesome
thank you ours like dude the podcast was
that Graham like cuz you were in a coma
stoned and I did talk the whole time you
were literally yes literally he was so
high he couldn't talk one time iron hat
and I had lunch and he was so high and
he's like I'll buy you lunch
let's go come with me have lunch I'll
buy you lunch he gets super stoned and
he'd the bill comes the bill comes and
he's looking at it and he's got his
wallet and he's looking at the bill and
he just hands me the bill and his wallet
and says help
there's no chance he was doing any math
right there
help I watched him look at the bill for
like three minutes I'm like what did I
thought they'd [ __ ] something up I don't
know something like somewhere in
Hollywood summer crazy Jones Jones maybe
I don't know thanks for calling in oh I
get a thing about I think for the bag
bags maybe you guys should just move on
from the past and just start new bag
bets and maybe make things like that's
hard to do less long-term stuff that's
been suggested yeah Sam likes that idea
by the way your son knows more than me
and Ari owns more than me I own one he
owes - Ari owes three are you gonna
storm out yes isn't it true that if you
don't pay on a bet then it makes the
whole idea of betting a moot point like
why do we even have a bag of bets if
there's no culpability like this zero
zero nobility yeah so I can stack up as
many as I want when I lose so there's
nothing at stake that seems maybe like I
own world they owe three and he owes two
people the worst ones for the longest
time how many dicks anyone's know I mean
I mean it needs to be 11 two years that
has been 2 years on this planet what
would be what a collar what would be
equitable I could tell you the [ __ ]
bet tonight and have my mouth
electrocuted and for the in a hundred
years from now the hot dogs I want to
balance yeah I think that like I think
one I guess short term good one would be
like if you lose it you got to send like
fighter in the kid like a dick pic with
your face in it like something like that
like something to do right away okay
I'll do that feel like you got your own
issues now that I hear please don't do
that right up for collar of the year up
for call of the year up for a cop dude
we have any t-shirt designs coming out
we need to make we do have the block by
Sam Tripoli and again I have to announce
that on this show because if Sam tweets
it
you will not see it because you've been
blocked yes so we have to mention that
on this show we have blocked by Sam
Tripoli t-shirts
Sam has blocked 400 people since this
show started yeah I don't block people
for the most part I'm punch-drunk unless
you're a real dick
then I'll balk and put the puncher on
but for the most part one block I'll
just block on my own mmm-hmm you know my
own thing but those are moving people
love them maybe we'll do a whole show
where everybody shows up and oh by the
way puncturing is gonna be at arms gang
fest so buy your tickets grab your
tickets we're gonna do a live punch
drunk pop can get all your information
at Ari Shaffir calm slash skank fest
yeah I mean who knows I mean he says we
can do it but let's see if we're
actually on to go back to go down go
down to the the re is running skiing
fest an intro bang that's so funny
ruins so [ __ ] funny yep there we go
it's getting first ari Ari back
yeah if anybody's listening this in
Australia check out Ari Shaffir calm and
go check our boy out while he's down
there I think they're for like another 9
10 days or something the lead singer of
tulle retweeted my show today how crazy
it is it that Harry Anderson died
yesterday oh my god I was like that guy
yeah nightcore was the Comedy Store
regular Night Court was the best he died
of like 60 65 very much do you know that
he uh he's the reason why they couldn't
redo the show cuz he was just he just
didn't get along with anybody on the
show really yeah I was always a pinhead
I thought I did I guess has a damn I
think some people just like they do so
we're at the age where people are dying
I don't know he look like ear muffs ear
muffs ear muffs we're all at behavior
people are dying stop it does your mom
like to call you up and be like hey do
you remember mr. Johnson you're a third
grade math teacher yeah he's dead mm-hmm
he's dead my mom that gets my mom's
nipples hard that's what she loves it's
just to drop the send me off for an
emotional response and
just drop hammer we had too many debt
real deaths lately
I mean uncle Gary but people have really
dropped a lot of old people have dropped
a lot of old people a lot of your aunts
and uncles yeah big family how many
brothers and sisters did your mama have
nine yep and three of them are still
alive yes mm-hmm
that's pretty cool the others the other
six died in a helicopter
one too you're on with tape Fletcher hey
what's up we're about Evansville yay
Pacers you got a couple Hoosiers in
there it is true yeah they are they want
a game one right yeah I lost Game two no
they haven't played game - yes all right
okay Devon play game one game two is
today okay see what happens that's a
good point dude if they beat that and
that pleasing team isn't good but that
pacer team is also a team that like they
made those trades in the beginning the
year and there was like they're gonna
[ __ ] suck what a stupid [ __ ] move
now look yeah I mean their books their
books are clean their books are cleared
they don't have all that got a lot of
cap room and they're [ __ ] winning the
Pacers are interesting because there's
certain people that can only play
they're like Lance Stephenson you bring
them anywhere else
can't play they're Indiana he's just
lightning in a bottle
hmm it's so weird they're ready that's
because there's no distractions there's
nothing to do in Indiana boy my god next
round they're gonna get house three a
house whoever wins the series gonna get
house in the next in the next series but
I mean dude you could be you could see
the changing of the guard here Indiana
Philadelphia lost last night because
they kind of went cold but man what a
good team Philadelphia is yeah Philly's
good yeah yeah
Phillies I mean obviously
[Music]
you got you never pay them off so
perfect dude I agree the people have
spoken
people spoken I'd rather go my life as a
welcher than the guy way to hotdog up
his ass and that's your son I got a hot
dog on my house right now
hey you're on with punch still the same
call what's the word no it was it was
that same guy it was yeah he just he
just made it and he's made it big oh
[ __ ]
hey I love you has it been uncomfortable
what this show I feel like sometimes you
seem uncomfortable well uh it's it's
hard because to interact with a guy
that's on his phone all the time
oh here we go you don't want to know the
answer here we go hi you're on with Sam
Tripoli and his phone seven seven three
in the house round with tape Fletcher
and the world champions Notre Dame
basketball women's women's I have I
think I have the first semi not fully
gay back of that okay oh wow it could
involve the three of you or just - okay
will it smell you later member okay what
is it
I like that he's got a name B let's say
t thinks you know the Denver Nuggets are
gonna beat the Bronco brontosauruses he
loses that that Sam has to work out for
a week and not wash that clothing and
then peep has to wear it for the whole
podcast
that's bad yeah that's bad way to do
that or I could choose like a third
party like I say this through you cousin
you could have are you and he wants to
work out would do it
you know winners winner gets the pick
who floats it out re doesn't wear
clothes that's true that's a good one
bro
smell you later that's like that value
later I'm not against that one
I think you'd work out harder to because
you'd really want to get a good sweat
going yeah it'd be incentivizing yeah
and all three must never work out so you
know be sweating our asses off on a
week's worth of workouts right to the
underwear
it's our last call oh we didn't take it
oh we did whoa he got us would an idiot
Oh Aaron who's after us
nobody did you get my email about the
divorce attorney I sent it to you but I
don't have have your email right and
what are you guys roll playing now I
mean because you got to be frying hills
blocked right Hill just hit me up and
said you haven't blocked I blocked him
on my personal one yeah well he's
shocked you don't believe in that [ __ ]
high eight to eight eight to eight done
there is punch-drunk how can we help you
sir all right boys I'll [ __ ] my pants
couple days ago yes cousin Jeff this is
our ace cousin he's uh
I'm sure take you fertile Colin yeah oh
yeah that's how he says hello hey boys I
[ __ ] my pants again the other day again
Jumanji worst world man up in there
Ariane take what up Abdullah punchy so
far up in there and all them other
people was he really that strong yeah
he's a powerful man I mean you've seen
him on the Instagram doing the weight
lifting yeah
yeah is it more of a proximity problem
or a diet problem the pooping
yeah the [ __ ] your parents I think
it's more of a mirror or a choking
problem and a combination of my after I
eat and you know it does cause my ass
almost of prolapse will be interesting
yeah a lot of times I'll get it like if
I have a heavy meal but then I have a
little coffee to set that fuse you know
and then I get in the car that's there
in the car for a long time and then it's
a long lot of steps to the bathroom from
there I [ __ ] in there once with these
peg leg jeans which I was thankful for
there was skinny kind at the bottom but
[ __ ] it held them in there because I was
at my front door and it was like a
horror movie where I couldn't get the
key quick and then so I'm sitting there
and every time I try to squeeze it it
opens again and voluntarily and I'm just
dumping loafs in my pants and I had it
all the way into my house and then I
made it into the shower which was good I
have a shower I just walk in to pull my
pants off and then I'm just in there you
know and it's you know safe because then
you just squeeze him down the drain you
know lunch after yeah anyway I just want
to see if it was the same for you dog I
loved that I liked a few sounds like a
coffee industry term interesting yeah
yeah it just always seemed appropriate
rogon told me his story of like when a
cape
when first got out he was living in
Rogen's basement for a while and then
after that Duncan and his fiancee at the
time split up so you moved out you got
your place duncan preceded me Duncan was
after you right he priest Oh Duncan was
first so Duncan was first and then you
were there and I was talking to Joe I'm
like how's it like we haven't taped
there and now the Duncan's ghani's I
call man it's totally different nine-day
magical like Duncan what he said Duncan
was like super quiet like everything
would be fine and then like Tate is just
like you just see these big shadows
moving around downstairs and like all
these noises he's had no idea living
like with Bigfoot right exactly
great cuz the first time ever did the
float tanks how I got to do them every
it was awesome I want to do float tank
they're in the house in Venice come on
let's do it yeah i think i think i would
get cost [ __ ] but i try it I'll try
I'll try yeah thanks for calling in
buddy we got a replication o'clock don't
you [ __ ] your pants or newest shows
we've ever done yes I think it was up to
100% I mean you guys both killed
thank you you're a little hard on me for
no reason Jay came in coffee coffee
cocom came in coffee cocoa music hood
punch don't get you 10% off of anything
get the night rose I [ __ ] love them
highly recommend it as always
Betty si.com using code punch 25 get you
25 3 bucks to gamble with and thank you
mom think patreon check out the patreon
guys go to the patreon patreon comm
backslash punch-drunk sports and leave
us some five star reviews everybody
let's keep this show in the top hundred
on iTunes hustle also all comedy
t-shirts calm and you can get all your
punch UNK merch they're your team shirts
your re shirts your tinfoil hat shirts
and then we got some 92.7 the pod merch
coming out shortly
Tate thank you my man thank you have fun
Aaron Johnny thank you guys love you
suck it